it is possible that the sex recession
socalled is partly
hormonal it's partly caused by I mean it
might partly be caused by women being on
hormonal birth control which is changing
their sexuality might also be caused by
men being
low so the low testosterone for men do
you want to hear my real horseshoe
theory for this okay right so I learned
this whilst talking to Dr Sarah Hill who
wrote this is your brain on birth
control right and um she taught me that
male testosterone levels are mediated by
the fertility of the women in their
local ecology so if you were a uh male
in their 20s but you happen to be around
a bunch of other men or a bunch of other
grandmothers perhaps are a bunch of
children your testosterone levels drop
interesting and what you have are women
who are very highly artificially
suppressing their fertility so men are
able to smell the T-shirt of a woman and
be able to pick the one the one that
they're most attractive to is the
attracted to is the one who is currently
at that stage of her cycle she's
currently fertile etc etc they can see
they've done studies where men watch
women's Silhouettes
walking and the women who are currently
during the 7day you can get me pregnant
period they're the ones that they most
attracted to the [__] silhouette of
the way they walk display high heels
replicate that that's the idea mhm the
high heels make you walk distinct make
you look so you have this recursive uh
feedback loop of hormonal birth control
causes women to select for men who are
more providers rather than protectors
they want provisioners right they want
the uh academic and the resources more
agreeable they then either come off or
don't come off birth control but find
that they come out this [__] hormonal
fug State oh my God who am I in a
relationship with but you also have this
effect on men too not only socially in I
noticed that lots of women seem to be
attracted to Timothy shalam who's
painting his nails and kind of blah blah
blah blah blah but the
genuine physiological hormonal response
to men just being around lots of women
who are on hormonal birth control
now processed foods not enough time
outside not enough time with vitamin D
not enough time with
friends but there's a big X Factor
apparently amongst uh testosterone
researchers who don't know why men's tea
levels have dropped the amount that they
have right it's about 1% a year every
year since I think 1950 wow so it's like
and then that goes to 100 and then it's
that again and it goes to 100 so it's
not how we're in minus [__] uh
testosterone soon but uh yeah so
hormonal birth control has a lot to
answer for I think it's a really tricky
tradeoff isn't it because
like there are clear downsides to having
a bunch of low te men you know in terms
of in terms of fertility in terms of men
and women just fancing each other and
like having functional relationships but
also like high testosterone is also
associated with crime and violence yeah
so which you know do we choose to have a
society of kind
of sexless incredibly like
online Placid soy people yeah who also
are quite
chill don't cause like enormous problems
I don't know that's like that's like a
genuinely hard thing to choose yeah you
could almost look at it kind of like a
disposition sterilization yeah in a way
yeah yeah [__] yeah but then we had
problems with like like this is a real
problem with the military I'm sure you
know like massive recruitment problems I
thought that was because everyone's fat
and got diabetes Well that too right but
also not being interested in it men just
don't want to wage war yeah we can do it
from Modern Warfare or um I'm on Reddit
it's probably also partly to do with
lack of like faith in the nation like
being less patriotic in general like the
pool of potentially great soldiers just
get smaller every year and it's sort of
fine I guess we get away with it because
if we're not actually in a hot war and
if we have loads of
Technology but you can imagine a
scenario where that becomes an enormous
problem like a mass mobilization I don't
know how we Fair the uh Chinese
government banned K-pop you see this cuz
they didn't what was it they called them
it was like [__] men we don't want any
more [__] men so it was all of the
Chinese male role models were like super
high te jacked dudes and they didn't
want this BTS Like
soy like culture infecting them that's
how they that's what what they saw it as
something I learned about that from um I
had a um R MIT who's a professor of
Chinese history and politics Oxford on
my podcast I didn't know this um in
China there's a very strong association
between communism and
masculinity and actually it's the old
pre-communist like Confucian soy boys
basically you know the sort of the sort
of like intellectual
indoorsy that's associated with
pre-communist China
M and so some of the reaction against
feminization through K-pop or whatever
is associated with um anti-communist bu
in other news this episode is brought to
you by cozy Earth we sleep onethird of
Our Lives do not spend 33% of your life
in anything other than unbeatably
comfortable sheets getting a good
night's sleep is the ultimate
GameChanger and the sheets that you have
are a massive determinant of just how
comfortable you feel cozy Earth has the
most premium bedding and loungewear that
I've ever found they're made from super
soft Visos from highly sustainable
bamboo temperature regulating so you
will sleep comfortably all year round
and an enhanced weave quality that won't
pill so it's higher quality will last
longer and you'll have a more
comfortable night sleep and wake up
feeling more rested and revitalized plus
there is a 10-year warranty on all of
their products that's how confident they
are that they're going to last but don't
just take my word for it Oprah has
chosen cozy Earth as one of her favorite
things for 5 years in a row now you can
get an exclusive 35% discount sitewide
on everything by going to Cozy earth.com
slod wisdom and using the code modern
wisdom 35 a checkout cozy earth.com slod
wisdom and modern wisdom a checkout
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip with Lise then press
here for the fulllength 2hour long
podcast go
on give it a
press